i have such an appreciation for
diversity and what
we really look like the more that we
dive into our internal self like we
realize that our physical form makes up
you know a part of the pie but that's
not just who we are i think it's gonna
have a knock-on effect for so many other
things not just how we view ourselves in
the mirror
so
i think we have to go there but
sometimes it's a really scary place for
people i know it was for me
i knew if i went to the deepest parts
of what is me i was gonna have to deal
with my trauma i was gonna have to
relive things i was going to have to be
honest with myself
and i would have to eventually accept
myself
and that's a big pill to swallow for a
lot of people and
i'm here to say though that it's a much
better way to live and it's easier and
it takes off the pressure i don't i'm
not here to bash plastic surgery
i think if you want to do something
again having that choice to do it that's
fine but
for me when i did all of these things to
myself i didn't realize because i hadn't
done the proper healing and i wasn't in
the right state of mind and i was also
just really young that was sophia
esperanza a true inspiration to so many
online who lives true to her convictions
and speaks to a deeper level of
consciousness pondering and reflecting
how the human species can grow and
evolve even in the age of social media
pressures and illusions i've been
wanting to have this conversation with
her for a while now from
stewarding our bodies to stewarding the
earth and taking care of animals as well
as the social media pressures and
illusions that we see online with face
filters as well as her perspective on
cosmetic surgery and plastic surgery we
cover it all including things like the
importance of growing our own food and
getting back to our roots so i'm so
excited to hear this episode let's get
into it
[Music]
welcome back everyone to the podcast i
cannot wait for this conversation and
sophia i'm so excited to just sit down
and have this conversation with you
because you truly radiate radiate
authenticity and especially with a topic
like this that can be so vulnerable
um i just feel grateful that we get to
talk about this today so thank you for
being here thank you i i'm just honored
to be here anytime that you know we can
open each other up for a conversation is
really important in this in this time in
history so thank you yeah for sure so i
think we should just jump right into it
there's so much to cover today and you
have like a lot of life experience with
what we're going to talk about so i
would love to hear you share
your story with coming from the modeling
industry to body dysmorphia to now
making the decision to get your implants
taken out and what led you to that
decision
right um yeah so my
uh my story in the modeling career
kind of begins when i was really young
actually i was
probably about eight or nine and got
asked you know in the mall by somebody
to
do some pictures and then it kind of led
to just being with a local agency but
really it didn't pick back up until i
moved to los angeles which was when i
was 20 years old and
at first i
started off by doing a lot of like
product modeling
i
um was working with like protein
companies and things like that and then
it evolved into
the next stage of my modeling career
which was mostly fast fashion i at the
time or was already becoming vegan and
so i wanted to find a way to kind of
marry the two this modeling career that
i have but also vegan
and
the products that i was were promoting
at that time weren't vegan so they had
like whey protein and milk and stuff
like that in them so
i became vegan
and i really thought that i was stepping
into this awesome industry of like fast
fashion you know no fur no leather no
suede no feathers
no silk no anything um and so that kind
of ruled my life for like four
plus years where i just became a fast
fashion model so
five six days a week you know 12 hour
days
binge eating at the end of the day and
going to sleep and doing it all over
again
and then
really started to have a lot of physical
effects and
when you're a fast fashion model
one of the things that i didn't even
realize was happening until i left was
we get flashed with a bowl
like you know five different flashes of
light from different directions
thousands of times a day and so i
started to have like headaches and just
started to feel extremely drained after
work but not in the way like just loss
of energy i just felt depleted on a
whole new level
and um yeah i think there were a lot of
effects from those flashing lights
constantly every single day and so
at about the same time as i started to
have these effects i also started to
dive more into the materials that were
in these clothes really it started from
just wearing them like i would get itchy
and i would wonder why the clothes were
itchy and felt like shards of plastic
and then i looked more into what they
were made out of and they were literally
made of shards of plastic
and so
um dope heavy into that into the ethics
of the companies that are working for
and with and realized that you know they
were involved in child labor harming the
environment
you know poisoning our waterways with
tons of chemicals from these dyes of
these clothes that in turn kill animals
and so realize that i i couldn't really
call it vegan
at that point and be content with it so
i exited the fast fashion industry
overnight i at the time was paying out
of pocket for
my
lyme's disease holistically
or just through eastern medicine because
insurance didn't cover my treatments and
so i didn't have any savings i was kind
of just dishing every single thing out
that i was making through modeling to
animal sanctuaries half or not half my
money but divvied up between that and
then my limes
and was like you know what
you haven't suffered in a while you have
this modeling career that you know pays
you really well and
you haven't struggled in a while so why
don't you induce a bit of struggling and
figure it out
you deserve to struggle
and so i quit overnight didn't have any
savings and the next two years i did
exactly that and just figured it out
with what i had built so far and i'm so
much happier
and so got out of that
and went fully into food which i've
always been in love with i mean we all
are we three times a day most of us
so i just kind of went straight into
that and picked up something that's been
a passion of mine for a really long time
and um i've just never been happier
really
that's so awesome you have such a a
stark transition from getting into the
modeling industry and then exiting it in
such a
grand all of a sudden way and where in
your story
with in the modeling industry does your
body dysmorphia story take place yeah so
i mean that's like its whole own story
right um
within the modeling industry
it basically just
um
enhanced or
ushered in
even more insecurity than i already had
you know growing up in
a half kind of like tech driven society
when i was young and then becoming fully
immersive at this point
i had a bit of time to really
connect with my true self without having
all these outside influences and then
you have the introduction of social
media and then things just changed for
me
and so i um
i guess i just picked up essentially
where i was with my body dysmorphia
before 20 years old and it just got
worse so
one of the things
that actually started to happen to me
was in the beginning
i
because of my social media presence was
asked to come on on these jobs like
big jobs that people had worked you know
their whole modeling career for had
studied for this and just because i had
a social presence i was just asked to
come on and shoot as if i was a
professional model i didn't know what i
was doing i
like the night before was looking up
like how to pose and how to do this and
how to do that how to make yourself look
taller because i was only five five and
a half
um
and so
really i was just kind of thrust into it
and i learned quickly
and so
one of the things that happened early on
was you have the monitor and they just
consistently look as you're shooting at
the pictures as they happen in real time
and i would come around to the monitor
and look i was so excited to be there as
you know my first few jobs and i started
to realize that
anytime that i would take a picture
smiling
everyone would kind of just push those
images to the side they weren't being
starred they weren't being used
and i was wondering like
why why is that why why are none of my
pictures smiling online
and then people started to ask me you
know the creative directors like you
know can you smile bigger or um are you
smiling like smile sofia and here i am
trying really really hard to give them
the smile they want and i realize that
it it wasn't um something that they they
thought was attractive or could sell
these clothes so they started to just
kind of cast those images aside and then
eventually just asked me to stop smiling
so
obviously that made me just turn wheels
in my head and it picked up
off kind of from the things i dealt with
when i was younger with my smile and not
being big enough and not being like
pageant enough coming from texas
um and
it really enhanced something that i had
with my mouth there and
i'll dive into that really quickly just
because it's specific to that but
basically
um
as a kid i was very aware that i
couldn't move my upper lip
if that makes sense so basically
when i'm speaking or when i'm smiling i
have to make an effort in order to
engage the muscle on my lip and the only
way i can describe it and i've only been
able to do this since i've become a
little bit older is it's like a mini
paralysis of this upper
part of my lip which i don't even know
if that's even what it is it just might
be that i'm hyper aware of this one area
because everyone's asked me to engage it
for so long
i think there are many different kinds
of faces and you know people and some
people just
you might be able to move certain parts
of their face better than others and so
anyways
i
started to see pictures of me when i was
young
were like my smile was just straight
across my cheeks were really big and it
really was like no teeth showing
and so that went into the next stage
which was me really sitting in the
mirror working on my smile looking at
things online trying to get it to be
bigger and and all of that so i already
dealt with all of that growing up into
my teens so when this happened in my
modeling career it just
it just amplified my insecurity
surrounding my mouth
and i went to doctors like i talked to
my dentist like is there something wrong
with my lip um and they basically
described it as you just have
more skin here than the average person
that makes it more difficult for your
muscles to lift it up
so um
some doctors even suggested that i get
the surgery where you basically cut you
make an incision at the base of your
nose and pull up your lip um
and and it would help me was never gonna
do that but um that's how far i'd have
to go in order to present a smile that
um i thought the world wanted to see and
so
um that was one area that really
affected me
and you can see how far it goes i mean
in just one singular part of the face we
can you know fixate on it so much to
where all of a sudden we're sitting
across from a doctor saying please fix
me
and um
yeah that that's one that i've had to
battle for a long time and eventually
now i've just realized
i'm not supposed to have
this pageant smile that's beautiful and
it exists naturally and for some people
it just doesn't and we have different
beautiful smiles just the same
um and really what it's made me feel so
connected to at this point in my life is
my dad i look at pictures of
my family members and especially my dad
and we have the same smile and why would
i ever want to change
my lip in order to
separate myself from something that
is is uh so
so beautiful and um represents my dad so
that's one thing
and well so okay before you keep going
it really makes me think of just how
pivotal something like this is for
people to hear because people clearly
just can look at you and be like you're
so beautiful she probably doesn't have
any insecurities she's just this
specimen of perfection and it really
helps people to take that reality that
like everyone has their own insecurities
and most of the time
the things that we're insecure about
it's something that we're focusing on
like you said fixating on and no one
else is even paying attention because
everyone else is fixating on their own
insecurity absolutely absolutely right
you you said it perfectly like we're so
worried about our own that we aren't
aware that everybody else is dealing
with it to some degree some more than
others and
um
yeah so
i mean looking back on that it just
seems so absurd and i wish i would have
accepted my smile a long time ago
there's just so many instances where i
think back to
you know sitting in front of the mirror
and smiling a million times over uh
trying to
look at pictures and mirror that and you
know what does my smile look like from
the side what does it look like from
this side and
um
it's just it's time wasted you have so
much
you know so much to do on this earth in
such a little amount of time and and uh
i certainly hope that conversations like
this and being open and vulnerable allow
people to realize that them quicker that
we get over these things that make us
unique that make us beautiful that make
us us the more time we can spend on
actually living our lives
and um
yeah so that's just one of the things um
another thing that modeling really
brought to the surface for me and
insecurity
was my scoliosis so i've had scoliosis
or knew about it since i was in eighth
grade
and um when you start wearing clothes
that are you know really tight on your
back and you have a flash that goes off
in your face you know back towards the
camera you can see like the actual
imprint of the back on the clothes and
so i started to see
what happens in my scoliosis which is
one side of my back protrudes more than
the other
and i literally during shoots had to
curve my back the other way and push one
side forward in order for it to just
look even if you took a picture from the
side of the front i would look like this
but from the back it looked you know
symmetrical so i had to see that all the
time and
also the the people looking at the
photos photographers and the editors had
to make me aware of it which is i'm sure
uncomfortable for them to have to bring
something
to my attention um just from a selling
closed perspective
so
that's something that it brought to the
surface it just makes me think of like
how much you know like we were just
saying everyone has their own
insecurities and being in the modeling
industry would just like exasperate that
times a 100 because people are pointing
out
these quote-unquote flaws or
imperfections that maybe you didn't even
notice yourself
right and and you know the mirror is a
beautiful thing we have this ability to
see what we look like and um you know
find uh cancerous moles on our body you
know or whatever it is obviously you
could do that with your eyes too but it
allows us to be with ourselves and and
look things over without having to ask
people can you look here can you look
here but man like the amount of time
that we spent in front of the mirror
screens um just looking at ourselves is
so
much and
i i wonder what the well would look like
if we just spent less time because i
know in my life the
less time i spend in the mirror the less
time i spend looking at myself on my
phone the happier that i am and the more
beautiful i actually find myself to be
when i do catch myself in the mirror
because i'm just being me i'm not um i'm
not performing yeah you're radiating
face isn't performing right you're
radiating your essence inside and that
creates that's really what makes you
beautiful but because like you said so
many of us spend so much time probably
especially women but men too i'm sure if
we had like you know recordings on our
mirrors and just put like thousands of
women just staring at themselves in the
mirror and what that would look like if
people are picking apart the way that
they look and dissecting it and looking
in a self-conscious way versus what you
said of
passing by and seeing yourself as
beautiful how different that would look
right
exactly and i think
in all my time
here on earth and diving into this
industry and just being on social media
because that affects all of us is
um
i just
i'm really excited for us to start doing
the inner work in order for us to see
the results that you know
extend to all the external things i we
we hyper fixate on things but we're not
we're not really tackling the true
issues and maybe they're not internal
for everybody maybe something is
externally driven but i think a lot of
our problems start here so we have to go
here in order to to begin to even
understand them and then to fix them
with with my breast implants i
started that i mean that insecurity
began when i was really really young
i've always been really thin
and got made fun of for that growing up
sometimes out of a place of just mockery
from people and sometimes for worry
actually like you know sincere
concern for my health because i was
thinner than most people in my family
and
not made me super
um in tune with the fact that i was just
really thin and people were alarmed by
it so
when i became
like 13 years old kind of everyone hit
puberty and i shot up this way but not
really out this way and so
um i had people make fun of my flat
chest and you know
just flat appearance overall and so i
couldn't wait until i was gonna grow
boobs
and then it was 16 and then it was
17 and i was couldn't still wait until i
was gonna grow boobs and and um
yeah i just
from outside influences like music
and the media and this idea of beauty
and also people around me at the time
who i was surrounding myself by people's
moms even
i
let that all seep in but essentially
made my own decision to get breast
implants at
in my teens which it actually wasn't
even legal to do what i did i had to
sign like a waiver because i got
silicone
and
as soon as i got them i went from an a
cup to a d cup overnight and cried as
soon as i woke up from
surgery and looked in the mirror i had
to hold it in a little bit um until i
was by myself and i remember just
looking at myself and crying
was that was that a positive like happy
cry or a sad cry what was what was the
emotion
i couldn't recognize myself i you spend
so much time looking at yourself for so
long and knowing your body and
i realized that the the person that i
was looking at on the you know other
side of the reflection just wasn't me
and also represented
a
version of myself
that was fleeting you know something
that i wanted to be sometimes and i
didn't realize that when i want to do
the surgery that was going to be me all
the time
and
not having
the choice to move from that form to
this one i was restricted and so
um immediately realized i couldn't
breathe
as well my my capacity just was
shortened um
and
are decreased and
i had rippling immediately as soon as i
took off my bandages i have what you
call a double bubble which is where the
implant goes beneath your natural folds
you essentially have two folds and this
one is rock solid because you have an
implant no fat um and then you have
yours so it can look pretty bizarre
and
there you go just added another layer of
insecurity i was like well they only
look good from this angle and you know
or whatever and um this angle i don't
want anyone to see so just another layer
of insecurity right and
i knew immediately i wanted to get them
out but
um
i kept them in for for a while and
it took me until i guess about three
years ago to
get what i thought was going to be my
full ex plan
and get them out completely but the
doctor said they my skin had been
stretched out for so long that it was a
better idea to put a really small
implant in allow my skin to shrink back
while he revises the fold essentially to
like bring my fold back up to where it
was
heal and then just take them out when
i'm ready after that after a year so so
that's where i'm at
and um i had copied or i got sick i had
a viral infection i don't know what we
can say out here but um i had it and so
it delayed my surgery a little bit so
next month i'll be if everything goes to
plan i'll be getting them out completely
wow so
it's fascinating that the moment you
saw the way you looked after your
implants that you immediately had this
feeling of sadness or regret or maybe
just a lot of emotions just knowing
all that you were thinking that hey if i
get these implants then i'll be happy
then i'll feel secure and confident and
then just realizing that that wasn't the
answer
that's really that's really fascinating
because i think a lot of women do
struggle with um feeling confident with
their breasts and i think it's helpful
for people to hear stories like this
that you know it isn't always
gonna just fix the solution fix fix your
insecurities
right yeah and
i think to
um one of the one other thing that it's
taken me this long in life to realize
obviously as i'm becoming more of age
two or already i'm at the age to have a
child
i see them
as a vessel for health for my child you
know they have a purpose beyond
um
aesthetics beyond feeling confident and
feeling sexy and yeah they give life
literally
and
i'm so grateful to even have breasts at
all there are people who wish
you know that that they had an a cup or
just nipples at the very you know least
literally women out there and so
i'm so grateful
to have them and so for me this this
word might be
extremely
um
i guess alarming or it might hit people
in a certain way triggering but to me
what i have done to myself
since in my teens whether it be
my my breast implants or you know trying
lip injections to try to fix this lip
issue that i had in order to try to
like as the doctor said it'll lift your
lip well it didn't it made it heavier it
was terrible and i had to dissolve them
um
doing all these things to myself i
realized that
the word that kept coming up to me
was i'm mutilating myself
and
again that might be a really triggering
word for for people and they might not
resonate with that and i completely
understand that this is the way that i
feel
and
my body is so sacred all of ours are and
i i don't want to do any of that again
i've done enough of that to realize that
it it hits me in a different way now and
um i don't want to cut her open
anymore i don't want to do anything else
i just i want to know who i actually am
because i think
when we're going to talk about this
probably but like with the introduction
of filters and all of these different
things we really
are losing ourselves
we're becoming more familiar with a
filtered version of ourselves an edited
version and it doesn't just have to be
physical it can literally be in our
movements right like a camera goes on we
start to act different we're aware
and
i don't want to lose our true essence
whether it be in this physical form or
the way that we move in life i want to
know who i who i really am
yeah and it sounds like
the way that you live your life and the
evolution that you've had throughout
your journey that you really live true
to your convictions so this is like that
next step to like
um living true to your convictions you
know like from quitting the modeling
industry because of fast fashion to your
ethical vegan story to now this like
you're sharing such a powerful message
about loving who you are and like you
said using a word that you know might
feel extreme to some but like not
mutilating ourselves and not filtering
yes i'm so excited to get into the topic
of face filters
because sometimes it feels like there
are very few people who are
wanting to not use them if i don't know
if that's the best way to say it but it
feels like kind of lonely sometimes like
most people almost everyone is using
them it completely transforms the way
that we're
seeing the way that we're quote-unquote
supposed to look and i think it's
causing a lot of insecurities um and
especially it makes me think about young
teenage girls and boys like and how
yeah how they're seeing that they think
what women or girls are supposed to look
like or even just if they're using face
filters on themselves absolutely
yeah so let's get into that then about
face filters but first let's put a face
filter on while we talk
yeah right seriously no seriously i i
mean i've talked about this multiple
times on my youtube channel and on my
instagram i'm like please guys can we
all just collectively stop using face
filters and i think some people try to
equate and say like oh well it's just
another step to like edited photos but i
really really beg to differ um a lot of
times photography is very art style when
it comes to something like face filters
in video
and you're smoothing your skin and
making your skin look
younger or even your lips more plumped
or your eyes bigger like it does so much
and sometimes when i'm seeing someone
use a face filter on instagram and i'll
click it and be like well how strong is
this filter and then put it on myself
and i'm like holy crap it doesn't even
look like me so i'm like i really don't
even know what this person looks like
yeah
exactly i mean
i think in this world
we should always you know we should
leave with choice you know no matter if
something resonates with us or doesn't
or we find it to be an issue or not i
think we will encourage more people
through education through conversations
through being more raw real vulnerable
to
move away from certain things versus
just shutting them down and i think
we're seeing that and a lot in this
world right like instead of
opening up different you know
paths and um coming up with different
solutions for things it's just
we're going to shut this down and that's
the way it is and i don't think
that's helpful for anybody
yeah so when it comes to face filters um
i used to use them for like uh skits so
i loved it when on snapchat they had
like the little mouse or the little bee
and um i would just use those because it
would alter your voice too and i thought
it was so much fun um but i never really
used it for anything other than that i
dapple a few times like when i first
moved to la in the filters but i
realized it was having a negative impact
on me
and
i also didn't realize that it was at the
beginning
it would hit like a few different things
and it would
make your eyes just a little bit you
know more pulled back and your lips just
a little bit bigger and your nose just a
little bit smaller
and
i didn't realize that was happening
because sometimes i would use the
filters after i'd come back from a day
of work from modeling so i'd have like
all that makeup on but i realized when i
had my raw face that it was pulling back
you know certain areas of the face and
it um it really just kind of correlated
with the idea of beauty in that moment
in tying right which was having bigger
lips smaller nose and more of a cat eye
so it was introducing this idea of
ourselves to ourselves
and conditioning us in a way i guess
and um
or what is it called grooming and so
i stopped using them
and then over the course of
you know years until now i
see people using them more and more to
where when i'm clicking on stories i'm
just like waiting to see their actual
face
i'm like where are you
oh yeah but
yeah i mean
again choice do whatever you want but i
think it's it's extremely harmful
because it's been harmful to me
uh i have sisters and i've had them make
comments about their features and it you
know makes my heart break in a million
different pieces and
um
it's really these filters i'm noticing
they are fixating on certain features
and it's it's this obsession with like a
smaller nose and bigger lips and your
eyes pulled back and you know clear skin
and colored eyes and
i just feel like no matter how much we
engage with it or don't you know say we
don't have a problem with it or not i
think the best thing for everyone is to
really
pull back and then ask ourselves why do
we even engage in it sometimes why right
um yeah so
yeah i think that a lot of times people
feel insecure like like we said most
people have their own set of
insecurities and it could be hard for
people to put their face out into the
world like that and this just helps give
them that extra layer of comfort and to
not feel as secure and so it seems
innocent enough um and i agree with you
it should totally be a choice i think
education is the key because i think a
lot of people just really aren't
considering the effects that this could
be having not only on themselves but on
their children as their children get
older and that this becomes like the the
only norm i mean just imagine how in
high school we already had our own
insecurities in the way that we looked
and just imagine everybody online using
these filters and then you yourself as a
teenager starting to use these filters
with social media and then you go back
and look at your face that you were
already insecure about and it just
exasperates it tenfold and i think it
starts to make this like you said almost
like a
one singular look of beauty like there's
only one type of beautiful
and this is it and
uh i just have so many problems with it
yeah well i started to see in modeling
something that was really interesting um
was
we became more inclusive right with
different kinds of bodies which is a
beautiful thing and in the same
in the same breath we still did all of
the same things that we did to one body
type to another so like still airbrushed
still pulled in the waist and made the
hips bigger and still did all of these
things and i really don't understand
what the obsession with
this ratio of um
you know certain parts of our body to
the other certain parts of our body
don't know why it exists
um
because
seeing so many different kinds of bodies
in this industry and seeing people
literally naked next to me
i've
really just
i have such an appreciation for
diversity and what
we really look like and so when i see
these people who represent more
inclusive ways of you know modeling and
just different bodies and different
ideas of beauty but are still doing the
same things
it
breaks my heart as well because it's
essentially the same thing
um just looks a little bit different so
i hope
that we move away from the filters i
hope we move away from editing ourselves
and you know making
our proportions different
because
what it is essentially teeing up is for
us to create an avatar for ourselves
which we're now moving into into this
digital world right like you won't even
just to be able to alter your physical
appearance in this reality and show up a
certain way but you'll now be able to
put that into a tech version of yourself
and then hey if you don't even want to
be yourself at all
why don't you just build yourself up
from you know the ground up
so i think it's
it's like introduced us into into this
way of thinking so that when by the time
that happens we're already ready for it
we've been groomed for this all along
and it's this disconnection to who we
truly are how we were born into this
world
and so
yeah i don't think we really have time
to keep doing things like this
at this point yeah
[Music]
and now a few words from our sponsor who
helps make this show possible
whenever guests stay in our home they
are always amazed after their first
night of sleep and ask where the bedding
is from because it's so incredibly soft
i tell them it's from buffy and they're
pleasantly surprised to hear the bedding
is sustainably made from eucalyptus the
bedding industry has a huge impact on
the environment but buffy decide to
change that their products are made
using only renewable and recycled
materials which makes them as soft on
the planet as they are on your bed their
jb product the cloud comforter is
covered in super soft eucalyptus fabric
and filled with fluffy fiber made from
100 recycled bottles it has over 18 000
five-star reviews and it is hands-down
the best comforter i've ever slept with
the cloud comforter is ultra breathable
softer than cotton and it keeps you at
the perfect temperature to feel cozy
without overheating and my husband can
attest to this plus it's hypoallergenic
and also machine washable the average
down comforter harms 12 geese but
buffy's comforter is cruelty free it
feels even softer than down while
keeping about 50 bottles out of
landfills and oceans and eucalyptus uses
10 times less water than cotton to grow
so use my code ellen for 20 off orders
over 80
you can try a comforter in your own bed
for free if you don't love it return it
at no cost
and it makes me think of a few other
things as well um
because when you think about the
insecurities that people have let's just
talk about social media because that's
where the face filters are um there are
a lot of people tearing down other
people and criticizing the way that they
look like if we're going to talk about
specifically appearance so on top of it
like if we're collectively educating
about like the importance and how
helpful it would be to just show share
your true self there's also the other
side of like if you're on the other
receiving end to
love and appreciate everybody's beauty
and how different they are and love
their wrinkles and love their
differences and not
criticize or be quick to judge the way
someone looks like over a screen because
that also like creates insecurities and
is one of the reasons why maybe women
are feeling well i just want to put this
filter on so people aren't going to like
pick apart my appearance and this is
this is for even people who are choosing
the face filters that aren't changing
maybe their physical appearance with
their eyes and nose like you said but
even just smoothing the skin like i feel
like even just that like if we could all
just see each other for who we are
we would feel less insecure because
right now everyone's seeing everyone as
you say online you're looking for where
are you really like right when are you
going to show your real face but because
everyone's only seeing
this like smooth
not realistic look of what no one
actually looks like in real life then it
just makes you feel even more insecure
about the way you look like when you go
and look in the mirror and it's like
this never-ending cycle
and i think what you just brought up is
it's a responsibility to
pass it along in a way right like if you
know that
which a lot of people don't in the
moment when they're getting plastic
surgery and they're doing all of these
things and i mean like you know
i don't i'm not here to bash plastic
surgery
i think if you want to do something
again having that choice to do it that's
fine but
for me when i did all of these things to
myself i didn't realize because i hadn't
done the proper healing and i wasn't in
the right state of mind and i was also
just really young
um i didn't realize that i was
encouraging other people to to do the
same thing and so
it's difficult to tell people and in
that headspace you know look what you're
doing or look look at the knock-on
effects of this that that can have to
other people because we're so worried
about ourselves we're dealing with so
many things ourselves
but when you have some time to sit in it
and you step back and you get a little
bit older and you look back
um sometimes the damage is already done
so i hope we could just get ahead of
that and it might mean
you know
uh
a bit of just
um
allowing more of the things that you
want to see in this world into your life
so you can't change what people are
going to do to their bodies and quite
frankly you shouldn't be able to if
someone wants to modify themselves and
they want to do x y and z let them do
that
um but that doesn't mean you have to
follow them that doesn't mean that you
have to hang out with them it doesn't
mean that you have to support the
businesses that they work for or
whatever you know whatever
however it
speaks to you if you don't want to see
more of that in the world that don't
contribute to it and it really starts
with yourself so
if you want to see more real in the
world you you have to you know be that
yourself and that's part of
why i've really just kind of transformed
everything in in my life in order to
kind of reflect and echo that message
whether it be the way that i found my
youtube videos now or how i'm physically
showing up to this world i just want
more of the real and i'm grateful that
the things that i've done
are reversible
i can't imagine
i cannot imagine what it would feel like
doing a bit of internal work and then
not being able to reverse the things
that you know you've done to yourself
truly could not imagine how hard that
would be yeah so
yeah that would be super difficult
thankfully that i think it's it's good
obviously like you said that you are
able to change that and i think that's
one reason why so many people are
resonate so much with what you're
sharing because you're being so
authentic and promoting such a valuable
message because like you said people
should be able to do whatever they want
to their bodies
but there's this also beautiful aspect
to how important and influential it is
to share like what you just said about
how you see women like when you would
all stand naked um in your modeling
industry and you're like i see all of
that as beautiful all the different
shapes and sizes the way we naturally
look without the filters without the
shaping of the faces and the bodies and
the more people hear that because really
it the echo really influences people
just like the way that magazines
influence people and social media it
changes your perception
so if we could go that way in the other
route we're appreciating the way that we
look naturally that would create
generational positive effects absolutely
because it
yeah and i think the more that we dive
into our internal stuff like we realize
that our physical form makes up you know
a part of the pie but that's not just
who we are and i think
when we think about ourselves if someone
were to say you know imagine yourself we
immediately think about our physical
appearance we imagine what we physically
look like and
i would like to see
when we reflect on who we are
characteristics come to mind
you know the the the things about
ourselves that are intangible
and
if we lead with that then i think we'll
be a world that leads with more of a you
know more philosophy than we do symbols
there's a real big coupling of
people who kind of uh
you know think with symbols and like uh
you know labels and things like that and
it's to me it's attached to physical
it's it's a representation of something
just like you are for
all that makes you up so i think if we
can kind of get away from that and start
to lead more with philosophy then i
think we'll be in a better position to
heal that side of things as well so
again going into yourself to do the
internal work
i think it's going to have a knock-on
effect for so many other things not just
how we view ourselves in the mirror
so
i think we have to go there but
sometimes it's a really scary place for
people i know it was for me
i knew if i went to the deepest parts
of what is me i was going to have to
deal with my trauma i was going to have
to relive things i was going to have to
be honest with myself
and i would have to eventually accept
myself
and that's a big pill to swallow for a
lot of people and
i'm here to say though that it's a much
better way to live and it's easier and
it takes off the pressure
and uh i hope
yeah i just i hope that we can start
moving through life with that a little
bit more
absolutely and especially this message
is important for mothers i think because
like you said earlier when you were in
high school you were influenced even by
your friends mothers and the surgery
that they might have had or the lack of
confidence that they had and something
that i've seen a lot a wonderful message
that i see in like the parenting
community
is that it's common for parents to feel
insecure to take pictures with their
kids because they don't feel confident
themselves and then the message the
message is like just take the picture
with your kid because down the road you
guys are all going to be so grateful you
have that picture and i guarantee 20
years later you're going to look back
and be like i looked so fantastic what
was i even thinking like why was i so
insecure and then that nether right and
then that other layer of just the
internal work that when we're internally
confident in who we are what we're
teaching our children is just such an
invaluable lesson for them to see their
essence and not to be obsessed with the
way they look there's this one there's i
was listening to this one
talk that dr shafali saberi she's a
parenting author had done on oprah this
was before i did my episode with her and
someone had asked her a question about
what do i say to my kid my sec my kid
says i feel ugly i'm so ugly and dr
shafali was like well our first impulse
is to say no you're not you're so
beautiful you're so beautiful because we
want them to feel beautiful and she's
like but what you really should say is
well i don't know what this ugly or
beautiful thing is i don't play that
game but what i really see is your
essence and who you are inside and that
is beautiful and i was like wow that's
so amazing something that most of us
would never think of because we're like
oh no no hide the hide the fact that
you're insecure no you're beautiful
beautiful and she's like if you ever ask
your kid when i tell you you're
beautiful when you feel ugly does that
make you feel beautiful and they say no
it doesn't right because they still feel
ugly inside cause they have to learn to
love who they are inside and that's what
makes them beautiful
and that is i mean that is what's
beautiful right like you can meet so
many people but really what will
resonate with you is how they treated
you how they made you feel
and
that to me is
that's beautiful so you know there's
beautiful people walking around every
day that we can be attracted to or
that we might even find ourselves going
like i wish you know i had more of that
or whatever it is but
really
the true beauty in this world is is how
we show up and and how we contribute and
how we make again people feel so
the earlier we can
really dial in that message to children
um the better off
we're going to have adults when they
grow up so i i think it's just yeah it's
planning those seeds and
it's funny too because
just in terms of like how everything is
um
you know it differs you have your
perception about things and i have mine
and
there's one
thing that i
i just it but it bugs me a bit um
because i see it as so beautiful and
it's one of people's biggest
insecurities so
um
when it comes to people's noses i notice
a lot of women
who have
these like beautiful strong prominent
noses
are some of the ones that have the
biggest insecurities
and
i don't know
how correct it is to you know just
tell someone you know i think your
strong prominent beautiful nose is you
know perfect and you should never mess
with it obviously
you know people should be able to do
whatever they want but
it to me is a shame because
i think back to like different times
like imagine if we were in
i don't know
just a different time in history maybe
that
part of their face that feature would be
considered
you know the just the most beautiful and
so for me
specifically with noses when i see girls
women who have this prominent nose that
might even have like a bit of a curve
here
i immediately
correlate people to animals and so i see
like a beautiful
bird like this this
this free flying bird with like this
just like strong strong face and again
that might even um
that might not be what people want to
hear but uh
i see it as a symbol of like strength
and
beauty and and so
yeah the nose thing really gets to me i
love
i love strong noses i think they're
beautiful
and it's like i'm so glad you brought i
have a really like kind of turned up
little pinchy nose and i love
i love different kinds of noses so
yeah i'm so glad you brought that up
because um i do want to get into the
topic of like cosmetic and plastic
surgery on fate on the face and you know
and the body too um but i think a lot of
times someone might say well what about
someone with like a really extreme
feature like a really large nose or
something that really stands out and it
the way that you describe that was so
beautiful because it really goes back to
the mindset and if your insecurities are
based on what the world sees about a
large nose because the world might see
or you might think the world might see
it as something negative or extreme or
not normal but when it's described in
that way if we as a collective start
looking at our differences as beautiful
and
even things like the more extreme
something could be a quote-unquote
extreme like like you said prominent
strong yeah just larger more prominent
yeah that it could be considered like
like just this strong eagle or like a
goddess that like you said back in the
day might be considered like a princess
type of
strong look yeah we don't have to act
like things aren't there right like
people say i don't see color right or no
it's not that big or whatever no say
say say the reality that we're living in
i mean let's not let's not create this
this fantasy world you know uh
i don't want i don't want anyone to ever
tell me if i'm looking at my back so i'd
be like your butt is just the biggest
thing i've ever seen like come on
you know just be a little real with me
but
instead of changing this reality that we
live in let's just love it more let's
just appreciate it more let's celebrate
it more i can't wait
for my child to come with me
come to me with something that they've
noticed about themselves and us freaking
celebrate like i cannot wait for that
moment to have that opportunity to turn
something on its head and say we're not
going to make that an insecurity we're
going to make that a part of you to
celebrate every single day because if we
really did celebrate it as a collective
then we would have way less insecurities
within these extreme features or even
features that are not prominent like
that like because so many people have
these insecurities of things that nobody
else would even consider you have this
insecurity like the thing with your your
smile that's not something i would ever
have even comprehended an insecurity
about so
i know it's a little it's a little crazy
that's why it just goes to show how much
the the messaging that we put across is
so powerful it really does influence
people and so that's why i just love so
that's why i was so excited to sit down
with you because i see the things that
you're sharing and i'm like this is
really powerful stuff it really does
help people to feel more confident in
who they are and to see the beauty and
everything and who they are inside so
yeah so let's get into a little bit
about what you think about cosmetic and
plastic surgery overall because i saw i
loved in your post when you were talking
about how we were going to do an episode
that you said
it feels so liberating to be able to
speak freely about something so
demonized and protected at the same time
yeah i mean uh
we always should have the freedom to
speak about something and i guess it was
me holding myself back thinking that i
couldn't speak about something and i
think that comes from again being in an
industry where people surrounding me
have a lot of things done to themselves
i had things done to myself i have
things done in myself
and
i feel like people feel it's a direct
attack on them if you speak about
something um you know it that's like
saying
um if you
i don't know uh you don't like orange
juice but the person next to you does
they
i can't believe you know i like orange
juice so it's like um
we don't need to we don't need to go
there we can just have a conversation
but
one i felt like
because it was such a
prickly touchy and sensitive topic i
didn't want to
i didn't want to deepen the damage
of body insecurity even more because i
know if someone were to have spoken
about certain things to me where i was
in a certain mindset it might really
just it might have made me angry
resentful make me get more things you
know who knows so i've always been
really weary about that but also
i think it's really important just to
talk about it as well because the
reality is is
something is going to negatively impact
somebody
no matter what you do you you can't have
a 100 positive outcome all of the time
and in fear of that we can't just sit
still and be stagnant otherwise we're
not living and so i
just
think i thought it was a good time as i
was getting them out to
you know speak about it and speak freely
because
it is it's demonized and it's also
protected and in the same breath and
it's interesting because it's almost
like this thing people don't want to own
up to they don't want to talk about
but when other people have it and people
go after them they're like don't you
know don't talk about them like that um
but i don't think the same protection is
given to people who are told you should
get this done or you would look better
if you had you know these things done or
if you looked a different way so
i think we just need more of that and
that starts again by just being more
real about it um
when it comes to the entire industry
i think it's extremely helpful a lot
helpful for a lot of people
um maybe even if you get something done
to yourself and you end up reversing it
later maybe it helps you get to that
point to realize that you don't need
these things so i don't want to bash
this industry that's done a tremendous
amount of good for people also that you
know helps burn victims
have skin grafts so they can be able to
live normal again um
help with people who were just born
you know uh with a deformity you know a
missing
an eye or whatever it is
um
or simply just have something wrong
where they feel uncomfortable in their
body every single day and need some kind
of transplant so
this industry is very necessary and it's
beautiful and it does so much good
i think it's in its application just
like everything else and so we have to
be
having more conversations around that
versus just this industry as a whole
it's just in its use how are we using it
how are we talking about it yes and how
is it becoming normalized um and how
common it's becoming so do you feel like
body dysmorphia might be exasperated
these days because cosmetic and plastic
surgery has become so common and because
of things like face filters
absolutely i think you know i've
because i've gone through it one myself
but two i've had friends and i've just
been around enough people to see when
you get one thing done to yourself
it doesn't stop there it keeps going and
we're just essentially upgrading
ourselves into oblivion and essentially
what we're doing is also just you know
we're running away from
aging and we're running away from
ourselves and i think they're directly
related and i think there's always going
to be a bit of a bit of it naturally
because
as human beings we compare i can't
remember where i read this but i think
it was with monkeys where we're one of
the only animals on planet earth that
compares and can get like
i don't know at the right word but it's
we compare and we can get down on
ourselves for that
and so
it's unique maybe to our species or a
few others but
because we have that we we should be
aware of it and move forward in life
trying to you know keep that in um
keep that in check a bit and so when you
start adding in all these other factors
it's only going to
to make things worse but
i think we also as human beings
in this new world that we live in
we have to adjust
and keep moving forward i don't want to
take away things again like i've said i
just think we need to adjust create more
conversations surrounding the things
that we want to see
and hopefully that will encourage people
to
engage in certain things for the right
reasons not just step away from them but
just think a little bit more about it
before they do things
um
but i can say that for me personally
taking these things out of my body
dissolving certain things dissolving the
lip fillers um and not using face
filters
has dramatically improved my quality of
life my mental state
and
the way that i actually treat other
people i mean the knock-on effect is
just endless and it's it's a better way
to live yeah i totally agree it comes
down to really um loving yourself for
who you are and not chasing this
unattainable quote-unquote ideal version
of beauty that just doesn't exist and
how we're all just so different
so do you feel like these conversations
that you
that you've had within yourself from
your transformation how has that played
out with your conversations in your real
life with like your friends and your
family well my family it's a pretty
short conversation it's
um
okay cool you know like it's just kind
of
kind of like that um my dad's from
mexico and so really traditional in
certain ways and so
he doesn't want to discuss my body my
dad loves me for who i am and he doesn't
care about any of that so when i was
getting things in he
whatever and when i was getting them out
whatever how are you doing sofia that's
what i want to know and so i appreciate
that because it puts less emphasis on it
and then allows me to not feel like i
have to explain myself out of something
you know he he knows my essence so
that's never really affected anything
with my mom too
she was really worried in the beginning
when i was doing things and voiced her
opinion and i'm so grateful that she did
and um that's always stuck with me and
as i've come back to myself over the
years she's just so happy so
it's been good in the family side of
things with friends
it's been difficult i've lost a few
friends
over it because as i'm talking about
getting things out they're moving
towards getting things in and changing
themselves and
they felt like it was a direct attack on
them and
you know by asking me
do you think this would look good and me
saying no i think you're beautiful the
way you are
that started to become like an attack on
them and so
it's really difficult because you're
you're dealing with so many factors it's
not just plastic surgery or no plastic
surgery it's what someone's going
through mentally
and
you know there's a lot of projection of
different things into this specific
topic but
i
yeah i've lost friends um i've had
friends think
that because i was
taking this journey in my life or taking
this
this path that i felt like i was better
in some way and i spoke from like a
place of superiority which can already
seem like that if you're vegan right if
you if you do certain things in your
life and so i've just been really hyper
aware of that and that's why i didn't
speak about it for a long time because
i don't want anyone to
ever think that because
my story goes this way and i'm speaking
about it that i'm casting a shadow on
anybody who's going through their own
and so
i think now
i've just chosen to do it one because
i'm in the right headspace to um
you know speak about it and i'm getting
them out but also because i think i can
put it
to words
whereas before i was younger and still
learning how to how to convey my
thoughts so
yeah it's interesting how um the human
psyche plays out when you're sharing
your own journey that some people will
take it in like either a way to just
receive it and say look this is what
they're going through be inspired or
just keep doing your own thing or take
it as a personal attack and it makes me
yeah it makes me think of just my
friendships in our mom's circle we have
i have multiple friends who have had who
have implants or um a couple friends who
had implants and then got them taken out
and then there's some mom friends who
are totally confident in our saggy
post-breastfeeding breasts and then
there's a couple who are just like no i
really want to get implants or breast
lift because my breasts are so saggy and
it uh it brings me back to this time i
was talking to a group of us were
talking to our friend who has had you
know
a lot of children and breastfed for many
many years and she's like look like my
breasts are so saggy now i should do
something about it and we're like look
look at my breasts too we're all showing
each other our breasts like this is all
of us we all have breasts like this
because this is what happens after you
nourish your child and it's beautiful
and we should all love it and just find
it
just this amazing incredible thing that
we were able to nourish our child this
way and just encouraging our friends to
be like you are beautiful just the way
that you are look i look just like you
these images you're seeing on the screen
of like these perfect immaculate breaths
like this is not how
reality is
unless you change something right
through surgery so like just that
encouragement of like i'm literally
showing her i'm complaining she's like
no yours aren't as saggy i'm like i'm
like they are trust me
it's just yeah i think that first of all
that's so helpful and that's incredible
because the more i think we do things
like that the better off everyone's
going to be and the more but i think
it's important that you do things like
that because
you just paint
a better picture of what this reality
looks like and
um i know because i've worked for people
for so long that have a lot of things
done to themselves again me as well
um
the surgeries just keep going and keep
going for a lot of people and
they are incredibly
unhappy and they're dealing with you
know
um
financial issues because they can't
figure out how they're going to pay for
the next uh surgery to upkeep or the
maintenance on it just gets you know
pretty can get pretty crazy for for some
things and so
it's just all these other added levels
of stress and
um
i i
used to
i used to say that
you know with once one of my friends
specifically you're so beautiful when
she had all these
things done to herself and i wish
i wish i would have
i wish i would have actually
uh
dialed in more to the message of
i don't need to feel bad
for not thinking that
a synthetic
version of yourself or a modified
version of yourself
is less beautiful than the real one like
i don't want to feel bad for saying that
you came into this world perfect
i don't think anyone should feel bad for
that and i think it's almost been like
reversed right like it's been projected
and then bounced back in order to put
the blame on the person who
loves someone for just the way that they
are and it shouldn't be that way but
again right doing that to you
if you're aware of that you can be kind
to them and know that it's it's not them
speaking they're projecting something
but
i wish i had more of that
um of a mindset
you know years ago when i was dealing
with the situation because i think i
could have put things much better
um could have been more eloquent about
it and i could have
really allowed them to understand that
i just thought they were beautiful
just the way that they were
so
yeah i think things like that are
important conversations like this are
important
and um
again do whatever you want
i don't think we need to to limit what
people do i think we just have to
encourage things for the right reasons
so yeah and just you know like you've
practiced multiple times in this
conversation that like you know if you
choose to do that like and you're happy
with it more power to you like you can
you can do that and like you know
accepting our friends even if we
wouldn't do those things ourselves but
on top of that adding that like i think
you were beautiful even before that
you know and that you didn't need that
and that's totally okay yeah because it
could be tricky right like imagine
imagine someone sitting across from you
and saying how does this look after just
getting something done
it's extremely
difficult to you you're thinking of a
million things you know well i thought
that they were beautiful before but then
you don't want to make them feel like
this you know doesn't look appealing
like there's some kind of monster now or
whatever so like there's a it puts all
of this pressure on the person and i i
think we can do we can we should start
having more conversations about how to
even
um
how to interact in that sense and and
and
what are the i guess what feels right to
say and can we just say those things
freely without having to think of an
angle
i think that would be really helpful too
um again all in an effort to
uh remind someone that
they're they're beautiful and their
essence speaks louder than their
physical form so
yeah i think you hit the nail on the
head right there so can we pivot a
little bit and talk about your ethical
vegan story yeah and yeah how has how
has becoming vegan changed you and what
brought you to it
so um
i was a vegetarian growing up i guess
from about the age of like
7 to 13 i know 13 is when it stops so
from a young age i was always outside
digging for worms and
playing with plants and just looking at
the small details of life
everybody was
kind of focused on like the dogs and the
cats and stuff which i always had around
and i loved them but i was so interested
and fascinated by just the things that
we can miss if we move too quickly
so
i
fell in love with the world around me
the natural world around me and um
at about seven my mom we were eating
something and i asked her what i was
eating she was honest with me
about it being an animal and i don't
think it was a very long conversation it
was just i don't want to eat this and
she said okay
and so right then and there she allowed
me to be vegetarian she cooked for me
vegetarian and
uh she was like pescetarian so every now
and again we would have like some fish
and stuff like that but just
two
veggie chicks
just
having a good time in the middle of
texas of all places so
um i know it was a little difficult but
at 13
i had girls at a slumber party everyone
knew i was vegetarian and they gave me
you know crap for it so they stuck ham
underneath the cheese
on the pizza that i was eating so when i
bit into it i didn't know i had eaten
him
and
i so desperately wanted to be accepted
with these group of girls and
just wanted to be a part of a friend
group
uh
neglecting to see that i had so many
other people who wanted to be my friend
i just wanted to i wanted to be friends
with the popular girls i wanted to be
accepted i didn't want to be known as
the girl with
hairy arms and you know a mustache
because there were weren't many people
who looked like me in that in that area
so
i just had a goal and i was going for it
and so being at the slumber party and
having that situation happen
um and then laughing and me figuring out
what they did in that moment
i chose to
laugh it off act like it was no big deal
and it was almost like the
um like the gateway the you know the in
order to become a part of their friend
group so i stopped being vegetarian that
day and started eating animals and
realized that there was also like this
camaraderie that came with it i was the
the talk around school for a little bit
oh he's not vegetarian anymore you know
she's just cool now or whatever so um
that kind of ushered in this
um
chapter of sofia
uh where
i realized by being big and bad and to
me
um
you know mowing down the small things
and overlooking those things by being
less compassionate it allowed me to be
more cool and more liked by certain
people so this i mean this
had a pour over effect into all other
areas of my life i started to act this
way
um was bullied for a while so i became
the bully
um
and yeah i mean it negatively impacted
my entire life by eating animals again i
mean it just was awful my health got
terrible
got so many health issues pcos
endometriosis
um
had sleeping issues
terrible anxiety mood issues depression
cystic acne i mean the list just goes on
and on
and then
at about
18
19 i saw my footage from my first
factory farm on social media it was a
dairy farm and it stopped me in my
tracks it was as if i just been living
life at a faster pace
and then in that specific moment and it
just i hit a wall and it made me stop
and
i
cried i kept watching this footage over
and over and over again it was of a
dairy cow who was getting lifted up
by a crane and then thrown into a
dumpster
alive and
it changed my life forever just that
piece of footage because i was
vegetarian for so long
i was like what what do you mean i you
know maybe the meat industry but not the
dairy industry
so
i decided that i needed to figure this
out for myself you have so many people
who tell you it's this way no it's this
way well the easiest way to kind of cut
through all that just to see it for
yourself
so
i
i've talked about the story before and i
don't can't get into the details but i
got into a factory farm
and uh it was a chicken factory farm and
it was a humane certified
organic free range
i mean every single label that you know
they put on these things that's where i
went and i sat there for hours
and
i realized that hell is a place on earth
for
these individuals
and we're the ones creating it for them
so ironic because all we do is talk
about you know the hell for us and the
other side of things and we're so
worried about ourselves
but we're doing it to an entire species
so
after that day
after sitting with those chickens i
you know sing tons dead on the ground
and
mutations hearts beating out of their
chest like
the worst things i've ever seen i
realized i needed to go vegan
so i set a path to go vegan and you know
going through vegetarianism again or
pescatarian to vegetarian to vegan
and
just set the goal and stuck to it and
i moved to la and decided to
immerse myself
into animal rights and part of that was
just by me going to these factory farms
filming uh for a long time i couldn't
talk about it
because obvious reasons and stuff like
that and i was really worried i did a
lot of stuff on my own some people go
with big groups and i would just go by
myself
and just wow thing and um
yeah it changed it changed my life and
it added a layer of purpose which i
think we're all
looking for in this life we're looking
for the reason why
we're here
and
for me that was it
until
you know i had my mom and my sisters and
my brother and my family but
until
until or i guess nothing had happened
after family to really give me an added
layer of purpose and and that was my
driving
factor ever ever since so
it's been a beautiful journey and um
in regards to all my health issues it's
just
cleaned it all up it's nothing i ever
asked for from veganism i certainly
didn't go into it for health reasons and
it's just
it's been the biggest blessing that i
never asked for and i owe it to the
animals
wow that's an incredible story like the
fact that you chose to go
see it for yourself as opposed to just
you know seeing it all the images online
you're like i need to see what's the
most quote-unquote ethical humane
free range and what does that look like
and can that be
only imagine what the other side of that
looks like if if that side of the
spectrum the good side is horrific well
you have all your answers right there
right
so how many years have you been vegan
now
i've been vegan
for over six years i guess now that's
awesome
and how has that shifted what you're
doing with your work and your kind of
life's passion because you quit modeling
you have the social media and now you've
created elbows on the table can you tell
us about that and what's going on with
that
yeah so originally when i was in texas i
was going to school
the path was to be a doctor
and
a lot of things happen that could be a
whole other topic of conversation in
in pursuit of that that i decided uh
this this this kind of doctor isn't for
me
and so
or becoming this kind of doctor and this
industry isn't for me so i quit that and
um
i
really moved to l.a honestly because i
was like all of these headquarters for
these animal rights organizations are
there and if i just put myself there
i'll figure it out even if i don't like
work for them or whatever it is i'll be
in the vicinity and i think proximity
creates waves and just by putting
yourself somewhere and it did and so
um
by becoming vegan cleared up my health
issues
um
it
you know it
helped with my relationships and my
family with friends connecting with
people
one thing it really did was uh helped me
speak so
historically have always connected to
animals and insects and little things
far more than i ever have with people
and i think my whole life has been me
trying to figure out how to interact and
how to connect and how to be accepted
and through the animals having to you
know now speak for them i've elected
myself to be a representative of these
creatures who are so exploited
it's allowed me to refine my skills
to speak for them to people
so it's helped me in just um
just relationships that way and
connecting on that level so i appreciate
it for that
and
it's
it's opened up this whole new world of
you know how can you be an activist in
this space you can go and you can go
into factory farms you can remove
animals you can
not remove them save them you can
go out and protest with signs you can be
a part of the legislative side of things
you can post things on instagram
horrific images and make your you know
your whole account just about the truth
behind this industry
but there's a lot more to it too you can
be an activist
by showing people how to eat plant-based
food and encouraging them through the
food side of things then all of a sudden
they've cleared up their health issues
and they're like wait there's more good
to this than just you know creating
less chaos for animals in the world so
i found a pocket that i'm really happy
with with food and i've always loved to
create in the kitchen
and it's just kind of the next step for
me and also
food is medicine
so
while yes i didn't
graduate and become an md food three
times a day i mean that's it right there
that's i think that's a huge part
portion of health and so
um
hopefully it'll encourage people to to
be healthier and
now with the food stuff i'm i'm kind of
cleaning up my skills with matthew
kinney so i'm going to ffi
i'm just refining my skill set there so
that'll hopefully open up the next wave
of opening up something one day and
having my own product
and then i'm also going back to school
to be a naturopathic doctor so
wow that's so awesome you're doing so
many things and i i'm juggling
yeah how many things can i add to this
yeah like i'm juggling all those things
and my silicone implants i've just
removed i'm just like
just add that to the jungle
yeah
that's so funny i i also know that
you're really passionate about um like
getting closer to nature growing more of
your own food as much as possible and to
me it feels all interconnected like you
said there's more than one reason to eat
vegan and not only are we lessening the
suffering on animals but it's better for
our health and also the environment so
to me this whole conversation does feel
connected somehow like being a steward
not only of your own body and inside and
how your mind the the information you're
giving your mind but also being a
steward of the earth and protect being a
protector
yeah
absolutely i mean that's what i i think
we all are and i think we've lost that
along the way
um there's such a beautiful thing about
being able to go inward and have this
this unique
view of life this experience you know
human beings we operate kind of you know
from this this place and most animals
they operate
i mean they see themselves as a part of
the whole and they're hyper aware of the
natural elements and we've become so
attached to that so i think it's just a
reattaching to something that's there
that's been silenced and kind of
squashed over time but i look at every
single person
as
that as a steward to this earth that
some of us just need a little bit more
help to be reminded of the
confidence that we should all have in
touching the ground getting our hands
dirty putting seats in the ground
knowing how to
yeah how to how to tend to earth and and
in turn have it take care of you i think
that there's there's an absolute
relation there and it's not a
coincidence that when you
take care and when you put intent into
something and when you look after
something it it's reciprocated so
patrice and i
my husband we are um we're just kind of
now making the next steps to find where
we want to do that you know is it in
montana or is it in costa rica or mexico
or is it somewhere completely different
so we're just kind of monitoring things
in the world and seeing where we want to
set up shop and hopefully
do it with um a whole bunch of people
too and create some kind of compound
spread out compound living with communal
spaces and
create a proof of concept for this thing
that might seem so radical but i think
it's so necessary right now in order to
get us back to
um
community we need community
yes absolutely so it sounds like is this
what you're most excited about right now
or is there anything else like elves on
the table potentially leaving late too
also are you gonna
yeah
what did i say did i say something
anything else on the table oh yeah
yes anything else on the table that
you're doing are you gonna start a farm
sanctuary i know you mentioned something
about that and do you feel like um you
do you have these goals to maybe start a
farm sanctuary and grow food alongside
of that is that part of what you're
passionate about right now
i i volunteered for a while at um one
gun ranch in malibu it's the biodynamic
farm it's organic it's just beautiful
and
um that's where i actually started to
get a bit of inspiration for
having animals on site this idea of
being vegan and then just having to like
not have animals around on your plot of
land i think is
just not for me
it's natural to have an ebb and flow and
to have animals you know
go to the bathroom
you know drop their feces and for the
ones that create really good compost
utilize that in order to make the most
vibrant compost that you can
i don't wish to separate myself from
nature and from animals i wish to find
harmony and balance
and so when i saw this happening on one
gun ranch i was like yeah this is
exactly what i want to be doing
um so i think
in a time where our soil is so depleted
by agrochemicals by
even you know vegetables and fruits with
our mono cropping it's just crazy with
these gmos and what they're doing i
think we have i know we have a great
responsibility to heal the earth and
part of that is by having regenerative
farms and so
i i think it would be a really cool idea
to take all of this barren land tend to
it a bit get get it to a place where we
can put an animal sanctuary on top and
the droppings from these animals can
help revitalize the soil because
you know these droppings are healing
especially cow
cow poop it's it's a beautiful thing and
so i think there's a way to utilize
animals in a way that doesn't exploit
them and i'm trying to find the cross
over there
and hopefully yeah just help heal the
soil so animal sanctuary grow our own
food
and um come up with ways patrice and i
are really passionate he's in the ocean
side of things into plastics and stuff
is actually his bottle it's the one
bottle
it removes ocean bound plastic when you
get one and it builds a home out of that
plastic for homeless people so it just
just does so much good and
we have just kind of come together and
just been like
how can we create the most impact and so
we're really passionate people so we
have like tentacles everywhere and we
just need to refine that and figure out
what that is but i want this to be more
accessible to everybody i don't want
veganism or
having clean drinking water to be a
privilege i want it to be something that
is just a basic right for everybody and
so
we're looking to
yeah to really dive into that in the
future that is so cool and not just
veganism but like healthy ways of eating
plant-based and eating vegan you know
access to organic fruits and vegetables
and have you also looked into worm
castings because that's a lot of what we
do here my uncle really i didn't know
that
yeah my uncle was like one of the first
people to create uh
to sell worm castings commercially his
his products called warm gold and so i
grew up like seeing him working on his
like huge worm casting things and that's
what we do here um we do a lot of worm
casting bins and putting that into the
soil and it's so beautiful to have the
earthworms into the soil
oh that's so beautiful yeah i mean
taking it and some kind of like race
leveled and integrating it back so like
getting it to a place where it can be
you know self-sufficient and then just
throwing it in the mix that's incredible
it's so nutrient rich but the problem is
what's so sad is that he's tried so hard
to get um our government um on board
with doing that on a wider scale for our
soils and the farmers but there's two
there's so much uh lobbying power within
the pesticide industry that it just
completely got shut down they actually
kind of went after him too as well for a
bit because they didn't like how much of
a threat he was because he was literally
restoring forest like almond like almond
tree for us that were like dying he'd
restore it with the worm castings and
like look we don't need the pesticides
and so he was and that's a bigger
conversation around corruption totally
right i mean that's a whole other thing
so
there were there's
so many warriors out there like that
that will never
get
you know coverage in any kind of way and
they're yet they're still doing this
knowing that they'll never get
recognition because they're not doing it
for that and so we have to know more of
these people we have to uplift more of
these people and we have to have this
knowledge being passed down to on to us
because it can stop somewhere if you
know if we're not
if if we're not close to it and so
um
yeah we we have got to band together and
if i don't know if you've watched have
you seen seed
no i haven't seen it i've heard of it
but i haven't seen it so incredible so
um i'd encourage you to watch it it's
about exactly that and um since i'm
native it really hit home
um because it just talks about
yeah it's it's just how the agro
chemical industry pesticide all of it
whether it's from animal ag or whether
it's from
gmo oranges whatever it is it's all
terrible and it's really hurt people for
for generations and so
it's
it's just a really it paints a really
real picture of what we're dealing with
because it's easier to
kind of
move through these issues if you know
where the enemy is where the problem is
and so things like this just help clean
it up so we can go oh
it's everywhere
got it yeah so right and also just
seeing how you're taking a personal
choice to really integrate it in your
life and create impact that way and then
it takes people supporting these people
like yourself starting things like this
and it just it it grows exponentially
that way and it also inspires other
people to do the same so that's
something that we do as well is like
hopefully inspire people to grow more of
their own food and just start with
anything even if it's just like a small
little square in your garden or even
like potted plants on your deck like
just start anywhere growing more food
absolutely because
what might be really easy for people to
do right now like just having a you know
one little pot on their balcony might be
really difficult for
that might be
a leap for some people you know
depending on where they're at in life
and
you know the all the disadvantages
they've had from the very beginning so i
want it to be
an option for everybody i want that to
be the absolute baseline anybody can put
a pot on their balcony or in their home
but that's not the case for a lot of
people and so
we need to get there and and if we can't
get there uh we need to be opening up
our resources as a community and and
sharing and welcoming people in because
that that should be a right in this life
that's beautiful well you are so
inspiring and you're doing so much good
for the world i'm so thankful that i got
to sit down with you and just talk about
you know dabble in one of the many
things that you're passionate about i
think i just think you're making such a
great impact on the world and i'm just
thankful for everything you do
thank you you too you're incredible i
didn't even get a chance to
to gush you with love in the beginning
but you're amazing and i've heard about
you for a while and i never it would it
it wasn't until you reached out to me
for your podcast that i was like oh this
is the person i i've heard about you for
a long time and what i really like about
what you're doing too on your socials is
you have a really nice balance between
like
your life and also
you know like not showing every single
element of it like when you have
children i see some people who just put
their children at the forefront of
everything that they do and it doesn't
really give them a chance
to experience life off of social media
and you did such a nice job at
integrating it but like into the natural
flow to almost where they're not even
aware that it's that it's happening
they're just existing and i think that's
really beautiful
oh i really appreciate that i try really
hard to be
conscious about the way that i put my
children online and only show them when
they're
like really wanting it and digging it
and um just not making it like it's the
kids show no this is like the ellen this
is my life and this is their
life
this is the ellen show and it's they're
in it obviously they are they are the
huge like the biggest part of my life so
it is definitely a balancing act um but
yeah i really i really value that and
actually that's actually one of the
reasons why i started the podcast not
only because i'm was just itching to
start talking about other things that
i've never talked about before but also
because i wanted to shift off my main
family channel and more into this as my
kids get older so that i can just kind
of phase out of it
it just feels like the right step for
our family and i'm thankful for all the
memories that we've created and like
have online like the kids watch their
you know birthday videos over and over
or even like scout was obsessed with
watching her birth video and the video
that's
like sweet
yeah so they watch it all the time
you know they love the videos that they
put out there and you know sometimes
people
say like well why don't you show your
kids more when they're having like
tantrums or yelling because you're just
showing you're making life look too
perfect and i'm like i'm sorry if you
think that my life is perfect then like
just please realize it's not but i'm
only going to show my kids when they
want to be online like i wouldn't want
somebody to film me when i was upset
yeah you know so
yeah so i just try to try to just uh
keep it more about this uh the the other
topics that i'm doing and then like
integrate my kids as well throughout
throughout it when they want to be in it
right thank you i appreciate that yeah
no of course
cool well i think we'll end it here we
talked about a lot of things
we sure did
i said this in my last episode because i
just recorded an episode with dominic
thompson i was like what the heck am i
gonna title this because we talked about
so many things and i feel that way with
you too
yeah i don't know i
good luck
all right well signing off now and i'll
figure out a title we'll figure it out
thank you everyone for being here and
thank you so much sophia
[Music]
you